what's up with gang Congrats again to G
Ramirez underscore three to three for
being the next winner of the Blu ray
infinity war giveaway for the rest of
you don't worry
the giveaway still continues there will
be two more winners picked if you would
like to enter the giveaway all you have
to do is subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
we have some official promo art for
Captain Marvel many have speculated that
the first official trailer for Captain
Marvel is just right around the corner
and although nothing is confirmed
Captain Marvel comes out on March 8th
2019 and Marvel does like to release
their trailers about 6 to 7 months
before the movie releases so if we're
going with the traditional Marvel
routine for releasing trailers we should
have a new one for Captain Marvel in the
next month or two and I think that this
official promo art means that we are
getting a little bit closer to it as you
can see here they put these on notebooks
to me this indicates that the trailer
will be coming soon because unless
you're a pretty big Marvel fan or you
watch the cartoons as a kid you're not
really going to know too much about
Captain Marvel so if they're going to
want to sell these notebooks they're
going to have to put out the trailer
soon to entice people to buy them so I
love this promo art I really do Captain
Marvel protector of the skies and I love
that she's rocking the traditional
uniform that she has in the comics and I
do think it means that a trailer is
coming pretty soon so let me know what
you all think
do you like the promo art and do you
think we're about to get a trailer for
Captain Marvel let me know your thoughts
in the comments below and again all you
have to do to enter the infinity war
blu-ray giveaway is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero thank you so much for
watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you
[Music]